Tại sao cứ quan thời gian nội nục thế cần chú động ra soát để xa định mình có thuộc dễn phải thông báo hoặc kê khai không
Lông thời hoàn thành đẩy đủ cấn nghiệp vụ lũ tệ hạn nhằm bảo đam quyền
Lợi ích hợp pháp và hạn chế phát sinh bí phá hình chính
Lợi về hô kinhzoan, cả nhân kinhzoan mới bắt đầu hạt động trong sau tháng đầu năm
Nếu có dành thuộc thực tế, phát sinh từ khi bắt đầu hạt động đến hinh ngày bảo mùi thành sau
Tư một tý đồng trở xuống phát thực hiện thông báo dành thuộc thực tế phát sinh trước ngày bảo mùi thông bẩy
Học sổ hợp vý điện tư sự giúp cho hạt động kinhzoan với câu quan thời gian
Tư phát hạn thành biệt thông báo thông tin tại khoảng hạn
Ví điện tư trước thời hạn chế, lợi về hộ, cả nhân kinhzoan cho thời mất động sản
Lợi cho hình thức khai thời chức tiếp, khai thời hà lần 1 năm
Thế hạn này cũng là móc phát thực hiện để khai thời lần đầu
Hoa ra các hộ kinhzoan, cả nhân kinhzoan kinhzoan khai thời theo cui
Có dành thu dự kiến trong năm 2020, trên một tý đồng đến không của anh em mới tý đồng
Hoặc mới bắt đầu hạn lợp trong sảo tháng đầu năm và có dành thu thực tế phát sinh đến hình ngày bảo mùi thông sảo trong khoảng ngày
Phải nục hộ sơ khai thời gian khai năm 2020, trong nhất của người bản mùi thông bẩy
Theo thời thè khóa nội, người nục thế có thể thực hiện kế khai bằng phương tức liền tư
Thông qua ở giúp ý trách smu vai khoảng công dịch vụ công, ngành thời gian
Cơ quan thời gian quyết nghiệm người nục thế không chờ đến sát tệ hạn bảo với mất tháng bẩy mới tức hiện
Để tránh qua tài hệ thống hoặc phát sinh sảo, anh hưởng đến việc hoàn thành nghiệp phục thế đủ quyed định
Bộ đối vụ đang nghiệp kiểu chính sách tện lưu mới thay thế nghiệp của tháng hiệm bài năm 2020
Dự kiến trình hội nghĩ chúng ở năm 2020, hành hiệm 2020
Bộ đối vụ đang giá tện lưu không trước, viên trước khiển chưa đặc ứng đầy đủ nho cầu của sống nhất là với người chai
Thương nhập thấp khiển nhiều người làm việc trong khu vực công và phó khăn về nhà ờ, giáo giúp và trăm sóc còn kại
Biệc trình bị phương tiét nhà ờ và điều kẻ sinh hoàn làm việc cho cả mộ công trước viên trước, chuyển về các trúc tâm hành chính mới còn chưa tiếp thời
Chất những mất tập này, bộ đối vụ cho biết sẽ tập trung nghiệp kiểu
Để sốt kiện quyết mới thay thế nghiệp của tháng hiệm bài năm 2020, về cảnh kách chính sách tện lươn và nghiệp quyết hành mi tảm về cảnh kách chính sách bảo hiệm sau hội
Trong đó, chính sách tện lươn mời giữ kiện lúc chuyện hội y triung ngâm vào năm 2020.
Để chuẩn bị mộ nơi vụ đã phối hợp với mang chính sách trên lúc chúng ơn sơ kết việc thực hiện nghiệp với hành mi bài
Bảo cả mộ chính chi, mang bị thương cho ý kiến mộ cũng sẽ xây dựng các phương ảm kại các tện lươn theo lụ trình
Thà miêu sự liên những bản đề phas sinh về tện lươn phụ cấp, đối vụ công trước viên trước, người lau đau và lực lượng bụ trang
Phu hợp với yêu cầu sắp sẽ mộ máy và hành chi quyền địa phương hành cấp và tinh giảm đến trẻ
Chính sách tện lươn trong phu hợp sản xuất kinh giói cũng sẽ được phần thiệt nhằm bảo vệ quyền lợi chính đáng cũng người lau đau
Quình kích nâng cao năm xuất và giải phòng sức sản xuất
Với mức lươn cơ sở hình hành lươn công trước rao đau từ khoảng 3 phy tư
đến 2 lòng phy bà chủ đồng mối tháng, viên trước từ khoảng 3 phy tạm đến 2 phy hà chủ đồng
Chưa tình các khoảng phụ cấp khác